vas-y mon bébé au fait le dossier de on
s'en fout tu feras demain pour d'autres
cieux
acorn a racheté la demain mais avec
plaisir mais bon c'est annulé ok sur
tout de suite bonjour je m'appelle
bernadette je ne regarde jamais votre
émission
mais on m'a dit c'était la meilleure si
on aimait les par cas alors je trouve
que c'est très bien en hiver mais qu'est
ce que vous comptez faire au printemps
c'est une excellente question bernède
mais je pense qu'on vous a mal expliqué
sylvia ne fuit pas les parcs ait fait
des dark à lédar cas ce sont des grosses
rigolades
c'est sympa mais ça ça tire pas très
chaud car et quand ils vous le savez un
cyril emery faire des blagues
alors quand même que quand il en tient
une bonne il la fait partager à tout le
monde
vous allez voir on peut la répéter 40
fois
deux mois
vingt deux tueries
m
tu connais jésus tu n'as pas envie
d'aller voir c'est loin mais c'est bon
je disais c'est loin dans la boîte oui
moi évidemment dans le jeu mais bien
avant c'est un petit gars comme ça va
mieux tout à l'heure bon évidemment dans
le genre comique de répétition le
champion sais c'est pas cyril c'est par
jamais cassé rihaoui
l'équipe sait pas si cameron l'a vécu ça
à l'époque mais il faut lier à benjamin
vient début d'année est assez compliqué
je vais vous révéler un secret il a pas
un gros moral en ce moment n'ont rien de
personnel c'est juste que je pense que
vous l'avez remarqué on enlevait la déco
de noël sur le plateau du coup il peut
plus l'arraché pour la mettre sur la
tête des invités à rester ce qui
représentait comme la moitié de son
activité dans l'émission donc pour les
faire un peu de bien aujourd'hui voici
des images de ces dernières blagounette
avant les fêtes
alors on recevait pas gaea d'ixia ton
métier jours l'appel et on sait plus si
vous ne savez pas vous avez comme
laurent boyer donc demandé à benjamin
bon voila et aux importations tout le
monde a regardé nouvelle star au japon
c'est un petit peu ce qui revient sur
cette émission on a également
et
merde comme cela
stéphane c'est stéphane bern la capitale
si ça relou
les
c'est ça et ça l'année
ce hameau fragile
allez parler bien sûr son animal vous
avez deux chattes
alors vous savez on n'est pas aidé ont
débridé alors hélas vous savez ces
dernières semaines la france a été
frappée par la tempête eleanor et nous
on la sentait venir parce qu'elle était
passée juste avant sur notre plateau et
c'est bernard montiel qui s'était prise
en pleine tronche je pense que niveau
vends cet adn aura pas mieux
recevez christian clavier
le levier trop lourd
robbie keane vrai
on embrasse question et on envoie ce
bernard enfin un bras secondaire et
c'est pour ça que maintenant on hésite à
cerbère noah bernard bach doit rien dire
bernard à côté des invités parce qu'il
ya mis et toutes les stars mais souvent
les stars ne savent pas qu'elles soient
mis avec lui le plus sécure c'est le
mettre à côté d'isabelle morini bosc
le problème c'est que bernard n'arrive
pas à s'y faire à isabelle donc à chaque
réaction d'isabelle il la regarde comme
si la connaissais pas mais vous allez
voir c'est très étrange
moi j'ai eu la chaîne
saint paul
c'est très dur d'être à côté c'est un
grand moment de plaisir je peux
témoigner mais allez passons au top j'ai
dans cette compilation des petits
moments étranges et insolites de touche
pas à mon poste
l'eurovision en tant d'argent donne il
envisage on va regarder à jada les
formidables faut partir en compétition
pour être lu mot de l'année s'est pas
fait
oui
non c'est vrai aussi c'est mélissa mais
ferme ta gueule
c'est le moment de penser c'est le prix
que les appels aux abattoirs ne m'entend
rien c'est comme je vais t'en faire je
vais te faire allégeance
c'est moche moi je pense que c'est juste
pour l'exercice de style
isabelle ne pense pas vraiment que sir
est un bâtard dans cyril est un homme
généreux qui sait faire plaisir aux gens
qu'il reçoit il a dix valeurs carole
j'adore les trois fois la et votre
animatrice
non j'ai dit j'ai de lune oui j'ai dit
une les animatrices préférées les
janvier
un de mes comics préférés et lui c'est
un de mes préférés
voilà c'est même mon patron que tu
adores les sushis je suis un fou de
poissons pas vous recevez bien les gens
à jouer pour le prouver je vous ai fait
monter le copil parce qu'il n'y a pas
que pour les femmes de baba noël que
siri de régal tout le monde
non lui c'est toute l'âme est un bâtard
c est franchement elle fait partie de
mon top 3 de mes chansons préférées au
monde entier hors et maintenait sa main
un peu plus longtemps mais c'était mon
monde
shine tu peux pas me faire un p'tit coup
de alors j'adore c'est ma chanson
premier au monde
qu'est ce que j'ai appris j'ai appris
cette foutue aurait dit n'avait que 16
ans c'est une de mes chansons préférées
au monde dit une des cinq maps que je
kiffe le plus au monde c'est vrai sophie
davant
mais te dire pour moi cette émission
c'est toi mais bien la chaîne c'est toi
bien sûr pour moi tu es mon préféré au
monde
techniquement c'est un des meilleurs
chevaux le dit et j'aime ce mec
franchement joli on parlait de michel
drucker tout à l'heure je vous jure que
c'est vrai mais j'arrive à jérôme
anthony pour moi je vous jure qu'il a
hélas et d'avesnes de michel drucker et
christophe je te le dis que son ami
maintenant non alors à la basse et je te
dis alors animateur préféré à la halle
pour moi on radio thé numéro un de très
très loin devant les autres
annonc les jeux inédits tous les temps
il faut l'accord radio top 100 ça m'a un
jour je vous met exactement mon top 5
mais chanson mon top 5 des meufs et mon
top 5 voilà de l'asie bah ça va faire un
beau teint savait très bon il ya
quelques mois nous a fait à tous le plus
beau des cadeaux l'arrivée de ludivine
retory dans l'équipe
enfin voilà le divine qui a apporté
beaucoup l'émission mais c'est pas
n'importe qui qu'il dit c'est matthieu
delormeau
c'est pas ma préférée mais est ce que ça
nous envoie un texto pour dire que je
trouvais que c'était le faisait que
c'était une ville à observer un mois et
demi il me le dira c'est vrai ça c'est
vrai mais vraiment bon alors
l'europe
au tour de main pour lui parler mais je
les adore aussi j'adore est temps de
passer à tous qu'on n'aurait pas voulu
voir et entendre cette semaine enfin en
décembre parce que la semaine dernière
n'avait rien et on commence par ce jour
sombre ou dans le sommaire de l'émission
d'annoncer aux chroniqueurs qu'on allait
revenir sur le départ traumatisant
d'agathe aux pros ah ouais une chanson
dans quelques instants à gâteau qu'on
reviendra sur les mesures prises sont
celles qui
pourquoi devrais-je 49 kg ouais c'est
fou je crois que je ne sais combien j'ai
rien dit mais non de massat était
magnifique
maman je le dis et le redis l'organe
fasb 60 points
c'est chaud
le tabac est une histoire à texte et
autoroutes
super tags mais jamais de photos si le
garçon mais là ça commence alors on va
appeler quelqu'un qui vend sa chatte oui
il ya une personne qui vend sa belle bas
du cycle et de la beaucoup alors c'est
maintenant il faut manger d'abord elle
pêche aura pas ce soir celle ci